il est l'une des plus belles promesses
du tennis français à 15 ans antoine
ghibaudo fait partie de la nouvelle
génération des tennismans appelé à
briller sur la scène internationale le
tennis une discipline que le sportif
d'un mètre 87 a connu très jeune j'ai
commencé le tennis à trois ans avec mon
père parce que lui aussi joué
du coup il m'a fait essayer et j'ai tout
de suite aimé ça du coup c'est comme ça
que j'ai commencé je me souviens que
j'ai tout de suite aimé aimer ce sport
très rapidement antoine s'inscrit dans
le club de sa ville saint léger en
yvelines avant de partir au perray en
yvelines
aujourd'hui ce spécialiste des surfaces
dures et fan de rafael nadal s'entraîne
quasi quotidiennement comité les
yvelines de feucherolles en étant
licencié au tennis club des loges à
saint-germain-en-laye la journée en
général c'est
je m'échauffe 30 minutes après je fais
deux heures de tennis je refais deux
heures de physique et deux heures de
tennis après et je finis souvent par la
récupération 30 45 minutes à
l'entraînement payant le sportif qui
sert à plus de 185 kilomètres heure a
été ces dernières années champion
d'europe par équipes est champion de
france
il a également atteint les demi-finales
des petits as antoine bibeau doit
également participer en 2020 pour la
première fois roland garros juniors le
tennisman a été éliminée au troisième
tour
forcément c'est mon rêve de jouer ces
tournois là on doit essayer de les
gagner aussi du coup et forcément
c'était c'était une super expérience
j'ai eu beaucoup de chance de pouvoir le
faire
satisfait
oui
après j'aurais bien aimé aller plus loin
quand même parce que le but c'est quand
même pas de se contenter d'un une
victoire au premier tour mais décide de
gagner les temps il est tombé comme ça
en 2021 antoine ghibaudo a de grandes
ambitions il espère participer aux
différents grands chelems et notamment
roland garros juniors et il envisage
également de disputer les tournois sur
le circuit professionnel mondial des
étapes importantes pour atteindre son
objectif
être numéro 1 mondial